we're told that a
0.450 gram potassium supplement contains
22 percent potassium
by mass
the potassium is present in the
supplement as potassium chloride which
has a molar mass of 74.55
grams per mole
how many grams of potassium chloride are
in the potassium supplement so pause
this video and see if you can figure
that on your own and i will give you a
hint you might need a periodic table so
i'll give you one right over there
all right now let's work through this
together so they already give us the
molar mass of potassium chloride
but it'll be useful for us to know the
molar mass of potassium itself and we
can see it's 39.10
so
for potassium it is 39.10
that's its average atomic mass but you
could also view it as 39.10 grams per
mole
of potassium i could write it like that
and that is i think all we will need the
periodic table of elements for and so
how do we think about how many grams of
potassium chloride are in the potassium
supplement
well what i could do is i could say all
right what's the total mass of my
supplement and multiply it by 22 percent
to figure out what is the mass of
potassium i have so let me figure that
out so mass
of
potassium
that is going to be my
0.450 grams
times 22 percent
which is going to be equal to i'll get
my calculator out
0.450
times 22 or 0.22
is equal to 0.099
0.099
so that's how many grams of potassium i
have and now i can use that to figure
out how many moles of potassium i have
and if i know how many moles of
potassium i had all the potassium is
present as potassium chloride because
then i'll have the same number of moles
of potassium chloride and then i could
figure out
well based on the
and if i know the number of moles of
potassium chloride well then i know the
mass of potassium chloride because they
give us the molar mass so let's do that
so
we have 0.099
grams of potassium
and i want to figure out how many moles
of potassium i have so i'm going to
multiply that times
one
mole
of potassium
has a mass of how many grams of
potassium
and we can see it right over there it's
39.10 grams per mole so 39.10
one mole is equivalent to 39.10 grams if
we're dealing with potassium so this
calculation will tell me moles of
potassium
now i have exactly one potassium atom
for every potassium chloride molecule
and so whatever this number is i'm going
to have the same number of moles of
potassium chloride but just to make that
clear i will write this down i have one
mole
of potassium chloride for every one
mole
of potassium
and you can already see how the units
will cancel out that will cancel with
that
that will cancel with that and so this
calculation is going to tell me moles of
potassium chloride but i want to know
the mass of potassium chloride so then i
will multiply this by the molar mass
times 74. and i'm going to do this
another color just makes it look nice
74.55
grams of potassium chloride
for
every
mole
of potassium chloride and so then this
will cancel with this and this will tell
me how many grams of potassium chloride
i actually have so let's get the
calculator out again so i have 0.099
divided by 39.10 divided by 39.10
times 1
times 74.55
times 74.55
is going to be equal to that and then
let me think about my significant
figures or my significant digits here
so see out of all of the information i
used i had this i have three significant
figures here i have three here i have
four here
i have four here so i'm multiplying a
bunch of things and dividing so i have
to take the minimum number of
significant figures which is three so i
will round to three significant figures
which is zero point one eight
nine grams
so this is i'll do this in a new color
zero
0.189
grams of potassium chloride which is
exactly what they are asking us and we
are
done